nas from
university of copenhagen
that's going to talk about instrumental
variable in sparse and dynamical setting
thank you very much
the stage is yours
yeah thanks a lot
for the organizers to organize this
workshop and
a special thank you
for making it possible to join remotely
so i have mostly watched the
videos both live and afterwards via the
website and it worked perfectly so that
was very nice and i highly appreciate
your efforts there so this was a really
nice setup
um i'm going to talk about um
two
sort of questions we have recently
been wondering about and they are
related to instrumental variable
approaches as you're going to see
so i should mention so here you see
some people from the copenhagen
coastality lab and the work i'm
presenting is a joint work with niklas
you can see over here and the second
part will be um john work with sebastian
nikolai and ricky
okay so instrumental variables we have
heard a lot about this
already during this workshop
so i'm
just introducing them again to clarify
the notation i'm going to use in this
talk
so we have a response variable y
we have some covariates let's say x1 and
x2 and we have some hidden confounding
and
we are assuming a linear model here so
the
continuous case
um so not binary variables as we're
going to see later but we are going to
assume linearity
instead so here y is just beta 1 star x
1 plus beta 2 star x 2 plus some noise
term
and now there are of course many ways of
talking about these instrumental
variable settings um so i i like to uh
at least in this talk think about this
identifying
um moment restriction
uh so we assume the exclusion
restriction so formally
i've written it down
in graphical terms if they don't mean
anything to you this doesn't matter it's
not used later on this just to be
precise so we in particular we're
assuming that the instruments so here i1
i2 are not influencing y directly
or
why are the hidden variables
and if this is the case
then we have this um
moment equation here on the left that is
satisfied by the
true causal parameters peter one star
beta two star namely that the covariance
of i
and y minus beta1 x1 minus beta2 x2
vanishes and why is this well
if you plug in the correct causal
parameters then this term here this y
term
what does it reduce to well this is just
the uh term g of h comma epsilon y so
this is just the hidden variable and the
noise and this is
uncorrelated with the instrument
now what happens intuitively if i'm
using sort of a wrong
beta1
and beta2 for example if the first
component here is 0 well
then this covariance doesn't vanish
anymore
and intuitively the reason is that i
still see an influence
from i1
over
x1 on
on y so these residuals here
they still
carry trace some
carry some information about the
the first component of i1 for example so
this is why the covariance doesn't
measure it doesn't vanish
now um this is the equation that you saw
before and now of course the
uh the question is well if you're
interested in the
in trying to estimate the causal effect
by using this equation here on the left
hand side then sort of this one
implication is not enough but we would
like to have an if and only if
and the question is well what is the
condition there and this is of course
very well understood
so here we have a full rank condition
for the covariance matrix between i and
x and here for rank means uh the rank is
really the same as the number of
covariates x
so if this is satisfied then we have
that this is really the unique solution
of the moment uh restriction on the left
hand side so this is of course very well
understood
now in particular this implies that
the number of instruments has to be at
least at least as large as the number of
covariates of course otherwise this
full rank condition will never be
satisfied
and what
we are
looking at in in this first pass
is the question
whether if there are more covariates
than instruments um we can
still do something so by means of this
classical approach the causal function
then is not identifiable um in in
general but
the question is can we still do
something for example if we assume that
the uh causal effects so this is these
are the red
arrows here in this in this picture if
this is sparse so if you're thinking
about we have a lot of covariates
um and we only have a sparse causal
effect so only some of them uh um
really matter for the
causal explanation of y so most of the
coefficients of beta star if you like
are zero
and this is the question i will say at
least a couple of words about this later
that we didn't start with is actually
coming out of the
um of an application that we looked at
but we stumbled upon this question and
uh
we we couldn't find an answer to this
uh so we we tried to solve it ourselves
but
uh so i would of course be more than
happy if
someone of you knows a relevant
reference there um
so in jova's talk there were some nice
references so maybe i'm also uh lucky to
to again to benefit from the expertise
that is certainly there in the room so
again just to clarify um the the
references are in in the paper so we are
not assuming uh which has been done
before and looked at that for example we
have lots of instruments and maybe only
some of them are relevant so there you
can also exploit sparsity but we are
really assuming that the causal effect
is spa so only some of the covariates
matter
okay and then
in principle we would like to understand
a bit
so let's say
we are looking at simple systems so
let's say even the whole system is
linear
so can we somehow understand
under under which conditions we have
identifiability of this causal effect so
for example in a scenario like this
do we have identifiability of the causal
function which are
just these
two linear parameters here for x1 and x2
and now i should explain a bit about
graph i'm drawing here so um
in the story i'm making my life a bit
easier by drawing simplified graphs so
the instruments uh these the components
of the instruments these i just draw
with
these rectangle
nodes here in particular there can of
course be dependencies between them but
they don't matter for the result i'm
presenting so we just leave them away
and similarly all of these can be
confounded so i'm just
not drawing any confounders here to make
the picture
uh a bit less cluttered
um so these are this is a question in
principle we would like to understand
and then of course you can also look at
scenarios like this
now
you can answer these questions and i'm
trying to
explain a bit like how one could
approach this this problem so what is
actually the method one might want to
look at in practice
this is the
solution space here
so basically these are all the betas
that satisfy this moment condition and
we
have said that the the causal
coefficient is is one of them
now
in the under identified case this is how
this is often is called where we don't
have enough instruments then this is a
space that is usually not a single point
but this has
a non-trivial dimension so this is a
linear subspace
and the question is now well
one of these elements is the causal
coefficient can we somehow find out
which one it is and here we are looking
at the sparsity assumptions so
one hope would be to say that well maybe
we can look at the
beta that solves this so that is inside
this uh calligraphic b here with the
smallest zero norm so with the smallest
number of non-zero
coefficients
and then the question is well uh under
which conditions uh is this equal to
beta star and this is uh
what i would like to explain a bit uh
i'm not going through the proof but i'm
trying to
convey some intuition and then at least
some parts of the results
something that will play an important
role
maybe i should clarify this is actually
important so as you can see here
the method of course doesn't assume any
uh
sort of linear structure of the overall
structural cause model except for that
the causal effect should be linear
and we don't have to know the causal
graph or anything but in the
identifiability
statement there we are looking at a
specific graph and
in particular a linear model which is
what we could analyze
and then formulate the identifiability
results
in terms of these
but of course for the method
we don't we don't have to make these
assumptions
okay so now
the
quantity that is actually important to
formulate these results is the following
this is a matrix that we call c
and this
um describes the total causal effect
from the instruments uh to the
individual
components of the covariates so more
precisely it's actually the uh
the js so the c i j it's actually the
slightly different from what's written
here this is a bit simplified so c i g
is actually the ice component of the
total causal effect from i to xj
and what is this so in this scenario
here
how can we construct this matrix c well
we just have to see how do the effects
propagate through the system and this
will be the crucial bits so somehow we
need to have enough heterogeneity coming
from the instruments propagating through
the system uh so let's see how this is
constructed
um the first element for example is just
the influence from uh the first
instrument on x1 well this is just a two
but if you're looking for example at
this minus five here how is this
constructed this is the if you like the
causal effect from the
second instrument to x2 and here you can
see well there are actually two directed
paths get a minus two from this path via
x1 and we get the minus three from this
direct path so they add up to minus five
and then here this last component this
is corresponding to the effects from the
instruments on
x3 so this one doesn't have any effect
on x3 the second instrument has effect
one
now this is actually a crucial um
object to look at and if you're familiar
with linear
structure causal models then this is not
a surprise they
these things appear if you're
solving the
linear structural causal models
and write them in terms of noise
noise variables
okay so here are the conditions one of
the conditions is uh small on purpose
you don't have to
read it um the first one is a capital so
what does it say it says that the rank
of a certain part of the matrix so this
is the this is corresponding to the
columns that are the parents of y so
these are um
uh these are the x's that we would like
to recover
uh this has to be large enough and this
is not uh surprising that this condition
appears here because we need to have of
course at least
as much heterogeneity
um or sufficient heterogeneity
in the parents itself so this is
basically what it's saying
the second condition i don't read out
because i i think at least for me it
would be the technical to understand in
a talk and what this is basically saying
is that um there shouldn't be any uh
sort of weird
uh um
weird matches of coefficients this is a
bit like
faithfulness saying uh you should not
have direct exact cancellation of of
directed paths and here there are
certain coefficients that should not
match up exactly and this is usually
satisfied if you choose the non-zero
coefficients
randomly
now if these two assumptions are
satisfied then there's the statement
then the causal coefficient is indeed
a one that minimizes
the
l0 norm in this solution space
calligraphic b so if you like this is
out of all potential
causal coefficients this is
if you look at the sparsest solutions
then the beta stars at least one of them
so this is if you like similar to this
one implication sign that i showed
earlier so now the question is well when
is this unique i'm going to to show this
in a in a second
uh but first i would like to
give an example where this second
assumption is set is violated um so to
hopefully understand a bit better what's
going on here
so this is an example where we have two
instruments
and we have
three covariates
and what you see here is that
we have a weird
matching of coefficients in particular
the two here is exactly the same from x2
to y and x2 to x3 and the one is the
same on these two edges here and what is
happening now
is that um this is a
sort of if you like this is a bad
example so this messes up
identifiability and why is this because
um you are trying symbolizing the
classical iv setup you're trying to
shield off the instruments from the
response so you're somehow trying to
find the coefficient vector beta such
that the residuals are not
uh correlated with the instruments
anymore and here the problem is that
the full
effect from the instruments that enters
y
um so this is a if you like it's four
times the first instrument uh plus six
times the second instrument this is
exactly encoded in this x3
so this is why uh here you actually find
it it's faster solution than the causal
one namely if you just use x3 because it
sort of it copies
the whole heterogeneity that goes
through the system in a in a single node
so this is a bad example this is what we
are excluding by a2 and here you could
argue well this can only happen
if you have this this funny match up of
coefficients
okay
so now
what is the last coefficient that gives
us a uniqueness uh uh let's
try to read this together so first of
all well if this a three holes then we
indeed have that the causal coefficients
are the unique solution so what is this
condition it basically says that uh you
should not be able to
sort of replace the parents by some
other set so for all
subsets to one of one to three that have
the same cardinality as the parents
we should not be able to sort of
replace the parents
in the following sense so the image
of the sub matrix should not be the same
as the
image of the
sub matrix when using the parents of y
and again this is a bit of a similar uh
reasoning as as before so
if you can just copy the the whole
heterogeneity in some other set then of
course you can use this as the the
parents as well
now these are very technical conditions
we actually
believe that they are at least very
close to
necessary as well we didn't uh prove
this but uh actually
we believe that uh it's probably can be
proven without
introducing much much more than this
here
but the question
i would also like to touch a bit up on
is
what does this mean graphically
it sounds like there's a question or
maybe uh
yeah yes can i ask a good question so is
that
because i think in the initial case when
the number of iv um
i think the rank condition that you
usually have to have point
identification in the initial model
seems to me that you need to have a kind
of at least
a
number of iv has to be
bigger than the number of covariate
right yes so how this is condition is
related to your a3 here so can i have
lower set of iv
than the covariate and this condition
with how this is related to the rank
condition that we are talking about yeah
it's a good question and we were
wondering the same
and i hope the the following result
gives a bit of insight there
so indeed this condition can be
satisfied if the number of instruments
is much much smaller
than the number of covariates but it has
to be at least
the same size as the number of parents
uh but but maybe so maybe the the next
result gives a bit of insight and if not
then please re-ask the question later
so we were wondering the same
so what does this mean graphically so
here again i'm
i'm showing the result and i hope that
it doesn't come as a big surprise so
what we need to do is as i said earlier
we need to have enough heterogeneity
that enters at the parents of y
and one of the graphical conditions to
satisfy this is that there must be at
least
the number of parents of white disjoint
directed parts not sharing any notes
this is what i mean by
disjoint directed paths from the
instruments to the parents of i you're
going to see an example in a second
then this a random coefficient is a bit
simplified now but uh
basically this is uh um
avoiding this match up of the
of the coefficients that i talked
earlier and then there's a third
condition
what does this look like this is a bit
more technical but basically this is
saying that
um
so you need to make sure that you cannot
sort of replace the parents by another
set of the same cardinality
and here
this this assumption is ensuring this we
can just read it it's not as important
as b1 so if this is now a bit confusing
then this doesn't doesn't matter but
just for completeness so so what does it
say it says that for all
subsets of the same cardinality as the
parents
um we need to have at least one of the
following conditions that are satisfied
so one
uh it can be that the
sort of the instruments that are
ancestors of the set these are different
from the parents so this just means that
there's different heterogeneity in the
set so then all is fine this set will
not work as a
sort of a replacement for the parents
but even if this is satisfied
i need to make sure that
there's sort of enough
heterogeneity in this other set as well
um and then
it's sort of all is fine as well and
this is what the second
condition here is saying
so maybe it's more instructive to look
at
at some example so this is the graph
that i have shown before so
we can now ask well um
if this is the linear system of course
we don't know but if this would be the
linear system would uh the causal effect
then be identifiable
and indeed the answer here is yes why is
this for example we can check are there
enough
distinct or joint directed path and then
read there is so for example we have a
path that goes from 1 to x8 x5 x1 and y
this is one path and then we have
so this enters x1 and we have another
path that is entirely distinct so we can
go from um the second instrument yx9 x6
to x2 so this is
these two parts here that i just
named
they are sufficient so this means indeed
there is
there is enough heterogeneity
propagating through the system and you
cannot replace these two variables by
anything else because
of this last condition here in
particular
what we're going to see is that
even though the ancestors are the same
there's so much heterogeneity coming
through the system that we cannot
replace
these these x1 and x2 which are the
patterns of y so here indeed the answer
is yes so this is an identifiable setup
for the next example of course
you already guessed it the answer here
is no so this is not
an identifiable setup and why is this
you can maybe just look at this for a
couple of seconds and you probably find
the reason yourself
so why is this not an identifiable setup
so here the problem is that even even
though i have what looks like enough
instruments
so i have four instruments and i have
four parents
and somehow this we have this bottleneck
in between
so there are three edges so i have a
four dimensional if you like
full covariance matrix of the y of the
eye so this is four dimensions but the
problem is they have to go through this
bottleneck of three edges and this means
that i don't have enough heterogeneity
entering the parents of y so here the
answer is no
um so i
i mean like
of course you can now do the
uh sort of do a consistent method for
this and
do simulations and so on you have done
this um i'll show the link to the paper
in a second
um instead maybe i i would just like to
mention this
um in fact we didn't
start with this question directly but
this is really motivated um by um
a joint project together with uh
stephen hill and sasha mugaji
uh this is a biological biological
application um uh that unfortunately i
don't have time to talk about uh today
but if you're interested i'm of course
more than happy to
uh to say a bit more about this and uh
we are also currently working
uh working on it it's quite an
interesting work i think uh we are
indeed you have and you can already
mention so if if you have a genetic
network for example you have a bit of
heterogeneity and certainly not
as many instruments as you have
covariates
and here the question is well can you
still do something under sparsity
assumption
okay so if
this is what's written on the slide here
so i just
maybe wanted to mention one more aspect
on iv and
in some sense it's similar here so this
is also something that we stumbled upon
when looking at an application when
estimating
price elasticities
and this is uh i will be short on this i
just thought
to share this because maybe someone else
stumbled upon the same problem and
so then people don't have to solve it
twice
this is a setup where we have
an iv but we have a time series
structure
in particular you can think about the
var processor vector auto regressive
process
and the question is can we actually do
iv there and of course the answer is yes
the question is just how exactly do we
do it um so here you see a var process
and we have the instrumental process
on top
and then we have a covariate this is x
so time goes from left to the right
then we have our response y and we have
these hidden variables h that we don't
observe
and now the
naive
implementation of the
of instruments and of course no one
would do this but is maybe to say well
we are looking at the
y t minus beta star x t minus one so
we're interested in the causal effect
from x t minus one to y t
um and the question is well can we just
now look at the covariance between this
term and i t minus two so this is the
yellow path here if you like and the
answer is of course no we cannot do this
so this covariance here will be in
general non-zero and the reason is the
red path this is a confounding path so
this is an intuitive explanation so even
if you have the correct beta star this
covariance doesn't vanish because you
have this confounding path that is the
red path
now how how do you solve this uh i don't
show you the all the formula i just uh
wanted to share the idea and some of you
may guess this already there's a bit of
a twist this is why i'm i'm mentioning
this so you can do something like
conditional instrumental variables
which i explained in a second but you
can also do something else and this is
what i wanted to share so what you see
here is now um this is without the time
structure this is again an iv setup
where we have this additional covariate
b
and this of course messes up the
traditional iv
the naive iv estimator in a similar way
as it failed on the previous slide
but here you can
just say well if we now condition on b
then everything is fine uh so here b by
condition on b then this is really a iv
set up
like from the textbook so we can still
use it this is often called conditional
ib
and i don't write down the the precise
definition here but this is a work by
brito and pearl and maybe others
leonard penkel
also has a nice i think a nice
characterization in his phd thesis
and now this is in the middle and this
is what i would like to share in the
middle there's this setup that is a bit
similar
and but now there's just one edge
reversed so we call this z now
and if you look at this
then if you are interested in the causal
effect from
then
of course that you're opening new parts
here so you cannot just condition on on
z but you can do something that this
sounds a bit trivial but that helps here
you can just use what we
would like to call nuisance iv and again
i'm happy for
i wouldn't be surprised
say that we are now considering x and z
at the same time and even though we are
only interested in the causal effect
from x to y
we are putting z into the picture as
well and we are estimating the causal
effects from x and z to y so this is why
we are adding a nuisance variable
this is identifiable in this case and
then we are just marginalizing and
looking at the causal effect just from x
to y
in some sense this is a trivial idea
but funnily enough
this helps in some situations where
conditional iv doesn't help
and here on the right just for
completeness there are scenarios um
where you can have either you can use
conditional iv or what we call nuisance
iv
the question is now well is one strictly
better than the other and the answer is
no not in general so if you look at
asymptotic variances for example there's
no strict ordering here
okay so and this this is what you can
also apply in these
in this var
setup so you can come up with
there's a general technique using this
conditional iv and the niv to come up
with these moment equations that you can
then solve
so this is not surprising but this is
what we needed for this
for this project as i just thought that
i shared with you
also what you need to do in between by
the way is
proving the
markov condition for these var processes
which are
just
a bit technical because these are
infinitely large graphs but one can use
sort of ideas that are a bit similar to
these
to this proof by stephen lowerton and
colleagues
about the equivalence of markov
conditions
in the case where there are no densities
okay so this is what i wanted to share
about this so this is one of these
nuisance iv moment equations the details
don't matter it's just saying that it
works and you can do this in in these
graph setups there's also a
condition for the unique identifiability
it's actually quite beautiful i think in
terms of mathematics you use the jordan
normal form something that at least i
haven't used for many years after
leaving university
but this is what pops up here
for
proving unique identifiability but the
details are on this paper
um according to my clock
i only have a couple of minutes left but
i think that's fine i just share maybe
one last
thought
um
and i'm curious i mean if people are
willing to to share their opinion i
would be happy to hear
um so we have been now also in the last
couple of years looking
quite a bit of course also into this
econometrics literature which is uh very
rich of course a lot of things have been
done um and this is maybe a
a personal
viewpoint we we thought that we found
that in that the under identified cases
so the cases where
we don't have this unique
identifiability this is um something
that is maybe not studied
a whole lot um
and there are of course good reasons for
this because maybe you are just
interested in the
in the causal parameter but this is
still something that we personally find
of interest and the reason is that
if you are looking at this um
at the space again of solutions and so
and if let's say in the unidentified
case you have um that the space has a
non-trivial dimension so
uh
maybe one or larger then of course you
can add further constraints as
i proposed in the first
first part of the talks for example
sparsity but you can also be wondering
well
are there interesting solutions in this
space here
um
and
so we believe
that they are and something that we have
done now in a in a couple of different
aspects is to always look in the
solution space and choose sort of among
all these invariant models among all the
ones that are potential causal models
look at the one that is most predictive
and um i'm not saying that we fully
understand what this is doing but i'm
just
trying to argue now a bit
so
one can of course now say well maybe
this corresponds to the one
that has the least confounding in some
sense so there are some trivial
statements that one can prove there but
they might also be interesting from a
distribution generalization point of
view
and mainly that uh well if you look at
these solutions then they they satisfy
uh a mini max guarantee
namely that
if you then look at so sort of you have
your training data
if you like um and when you look at this
uh most predictive invariant solution
then this solution satisfies a mini max
criteria namely it is the best predictor
um under the worst case intervention on
the instruments
this is a
sort of a guarantee so
the hope is that this may help for
distribution generalization
because these are sort of both stable
and predictive solutions and this is the
guarantee um
maybe
someone if
if someone is interested
can just pause the video here i'm just
saying there's an optimality guarantee
and this is a very simple argument for
the linear iv setup and we have been
looking at this from uh sort of very
different different angles um and i'm
not going into details here but the the
same reasoning sort of you can apply in
learning chemical reaction networks this
is what we have done so again always
with the idea that well in many of these
applications you have a bit of
heterogeneity but certainly not enough
to identify causal effects so
usually the dimension is much smaller
than the number of covariates but how
can we still use this and the idea is to
say well we use these few instruments to
constrain the space and then look at the
most predictive one and of course i'm
aware this is a bit hand-wavy but it
actually worked in a couple of
applications that we looked at so this
is a chemical reaction network example
we also looked at this uh in
reinforcement learning recently you can
do similar things there
and and
but this is just a if you like
maybe a thought provoking um
comment uh here to conclude my talk
okay so what did i talk about um
i talked about instrumental variables
in these sparse models so the
identifiability
one can just
sort of compute the condition this is
what i
presented there
and as well in dynamical models yeah i
didn't have time today at least to talk
about the
motivating examples here and then the
last bit this is really just a proposal
i didn't talk much about this but to say
that maybe these under identified cases
this is at least something we are
personally interested in
and the proposal is to say among all
these invariant models choose the best
predictive one
this often minimizes these worst case
prediction errors so worst case
in terms of the worst case intervention
on the instruments let's say
okay so this is uh oh what i wanted to
talk about that the time is up
and i'm more than happy to
try to answer any questions in case
there are some
so just one reference uh as you said the
econometrics literature is gigantic and
uh maybe ismail knows more references uh
but the um
lima ed lima in his uh specification
search his book he does consider a
little bit uh different specifications
and sort of
iv versus forward regression versus
backward regression and taking a
reciprocal and then trying to work out
and he does have some papers where he
considered that under identified case
yes so okay thanks a lot for that i
would be uh actually i'm not sure
i know this particular reference so i
would be more than happy to if you can
put it in the chat for example um and i
should clarify of course people are
starting their under identifier case
this is there's
lots of papers on this um
and this was just a comment maybe saying
that uh we feel it's it's a bit maybe
underexplored so not to the extent that
people are starting the identified or
the over-identified case this was only
our impression but of course it's not
the case that no one looks at the
underdamned fight it's just that we felt
there's there may be
a bit more
uh things one can say about these
situations
i think it's right
i was going to say i think it is right
that the under-identified case is less
studied
and i think
to some extent it's that when people
start to think about things
non-parametrically that they started
doing it so i think that looking at
things that are under identified in a
parametric setting people typically will
just say you know i'll try and find
another instrument and then
then assume it is identified but i don't
know it's now i might take a different
view
yeah i agree with thomas i i was kind of
curious about your your results about
point identification in the case when
you have less
iv that the covariate and then the
condition that you put but because your
your equation is linear i was wondering
i assume that i have like
a lower i have two covariate and one
one iv
and in that case because it is linear i
can just construct some iv in the
different way i can put z and say that z
squared times x
and construct this as a potential kind
of iv and then try to inflate a little
bit my model and try to
get back to this rank condition and get
point identification can i how this
method is related to the condition that
you are
here so maybe i can
follow up a bit on this so of course we
need the sparsity right so this is a bit
of the degenerate example if you have
one instrument the two covariates but
just to make clear clear right so there
it can only ever work if the true causal
coefficient has one zero component right
because if we only if you have one
instrument and we have two causal
parents then uh this identifiability
assumptions never hold that are
presented so you need as
as many at least as many instruments as
you have sort of non-zeros in your
causal coefficient
and then in principle i mean there are
scenarios where these
assumptions are satisfied and even in
this setup that you described um
i should also maybe say the idea is
really that you have uh sort of the
heterogeneity entering the system so we
are more thing i mean i could imagine
i've not worked this out but i could
imagine that these
conditions are a bit funny in this case
of one instrument and two covariates
because probably
i think it would give a good nutrition
and a good flavor to see a little bit
i'm curious to see yeah but
but anybody so maybe if i can just say
if you think about this scenario here
right
uh a scenario like this
so here this is a typical identified
scenario where you have sort of
you have at least two instruments going
to the
to the parents and then for example if
you have one additional instrument then
that propagates through the system then
this is usually sufficient to identify
um to to
satisfy these identifiability
assumptions and the reason is that you
cannot replace these two parents by
something else
but you're right there we we of course
should work this this assumption through
in the
in the in the simple case that you
described it it was probably instructive
yeah but this is at least not the
setting that we had in mind for our
applications there
right and if i may add one thing
so the linearity it's a bit funny
because of course this seems like a
strong assumption
and it is it's just something that we
could analyze
our intuition so nicholas and my
intuition is um that
this really becomes
in a way
the assumptions become weaker in the
non-linear case
but we
haven't looked into this and i don't
actually know how hard this would be to
prove even um but the intuition is that
so it's really that if
if these assumptions don't hold then
this is because you can somehow copy
this heterogeneity
of the instruments in in some other
covariates let's say in in three and
four is not the case in this graph but
in
this would be a failure of
identifiability if the you have the same
sort of instrument influence in these
two two variables and we believe this is
much
much less likely to happen if you have
non-linearities because then they
all these heterogeneities get
sort of strummed up but this is
something that
we this is completely only a guess there
so this is our intuition and we don't
have any results in this
okay i
i think let's thanks uh jeunesse for the
wonderful day
[Applause]
yeah thanks again and enjoy the rest of
the workshop i i will i know i will